pépin le bref à son apogée chasse les
musulmans de la septimanie et
reconquièrent l'aquitaine laissant à ses
fils car le mans et charlemagne un
royaume franc étendue et puissant mais
carloman moeurs charlemagne s'empare
alors de ces territoires et roi guerrier
repousse les musulmans du nord de
l'espagne conquiert l'italie du nord et
annexes les pays germain enfin se posent
en défenseurs de l'église
il donne au pape la corse et des
possessions dans le centre de l'italie
permettant la création des états
pontificaux
il est alors sacré empereur romain
d'occident
avec toutes les magnificence et les
titres de l'ancienne rome
charlemagne établi sa capitale à
aix-la-chapelle et fut le souverain le
plus puissant de l'europe médiévale mais
son énorme empire morcelée en une
multitude de principauté avec coutumes
et langues différentes étaient
difficiles à unifier au traité de verdun
il sera donc partagée entre les trois
petits fils de charlemagne
charles le chauve reçoit la francie
occidentale qui est l'ancien france
lothaire premier à qui échoit le titre
impérial reçoit la france y médiane qui
sera la lotharingie louis le germanique
reçoit la france y orientale appelés
germany qui est l'ancienne allemagne
mais un grand danger arrive de la
scandinavie lewicki normands après avoir
dévasté les îles britanniques débarquent
par la scène ravageant tout jusqu'à
paris
au lieu de les combattre
le roi de france charles le chauve paye
les normands pour qu'ils repartent en
asie reste de cette faiblesse de charles
le chauve le conte breton nominaux et
profite à l'or il balaie francs leur
enlève des territoires et se proclame
roi de bretagne à la mort des trois
frères souverain le fils de louis le
germanique charles legros hérite de la
germanie et de la france y tandis que
les trois fils de lothaire hérite de la
lotharingie la divisant en lorraine
bourgogne et italie
charles le gros roi de germanie et de
francie séparés par la seule lotharingie
avait l'ambition de reconstituer lempire
de charlemagne il permis dont aux
normands le saccage et la bourgogne qui
réclamaient l'indépendance
cela provoque au contraire une terrible
colère des nobles francs charles legros
est alors destitué et arnulf de
carinthie est élu roi de germanie peu de
premiers marquis de neustrie est élu roi
de france y en attendant que charles le
simple deviennent majeurs et rodolphe
premiers libérés les normands se
proclame roi de bourgogne
charles le simple devenu roi de france y
préférant négocier avec les normands qui
pillaient son territoire sous la
promesse qu'ils cessent leurs raids
il leur donna même à duché
mais les normands
bien qu'ils se soient fait baptiser et
qu'il jurèrent obéissance en tant que
vassaux de francis saccagèrent l'anjou
le comte robert d'anjou se rebella alors
accusé charles le simple de faiblesse et
le pâtis se proclamant roi de france est
à sa place
mais charles le simple contre attaqua et
repris le royaume
son fils
8,4 d'outre-mer eu des ambitions de
conquête
il tenta d'annexer la lorraine mais fut
battu par les germains et perdit prince
il tenta alors de conquérir la normandie
mais fut capturée par les normands et
une fois libérés ils du même se protéger
des bourguignons son fils lothaire et
rita dont d'une couronne de france
instable des vassaux plus puissant que
le roi menaçait le trône et dans leur
fief il imposait les institutions féodal
et les impôts à leurs paysans dans les
pays slaves
entre temps les états de pologne et de
tchéquie à peine né était ravagé par un
peuple provenant du ral les hongrois qui
arrivèrent même appuyer les terres des
germains mais au tout premier le très
puissant roi de germanie avait des
ambitions impériales il bâtit les
hongrois et stoppa leurs incursions
fondant le marquisat d'autriche
puis il envahit la bourdonne et l'italie
rentrer en triomphant dans rome le pape
toujours en quête le protecteur le
couronna alors empereur du saint empire
romain germanique
c'est le premier prêche
en france si la lutte pour le trône est
terminée les nobles avait écarté l'hôte
est réélu à sa place le comte de paris
hugues capet mais son domaine royal au
coeur de l'île de france étaient trop
petits ce qui relance à les esprit de
conquête
les bretons annexe le comté de nantes
le conte danger enlève tour aux comptes
doit le duc d'aquitaine annexe le sud de
la france yves les byzantins brain la
bulgarie et les normands occupent le sud
de l'italie en france i dévastée par les
batailles le peuple n'en peut plus
l'église ou valor le moyen de réunir les
seigneurs et de leur faire jurer la fête
c'est la paix de dieu
mais guillaume le conquérant duc de
normandie et vassal de francs si malgré
la base morale de la société médiévale à
peine fondé s'empare de l'île
britannique et se proclame roi
d'angleterre
la violence reprend guillaume le
conquérant et repousse et l'irlande les
comptes d'anjou annexe les pays de la
loire les comtes de toulouse et d'aragon
se partagent la provence et l'évêché
d'avignon déclare son indépendance les
musulmans chassé de la méditerranée par
jane des peas sont battus aussi par les
espagnols et les portugais tandis que
les roumains sont repoussés par les
byzantins
déjà un nouveau grand danger menace la
france y le comte d'anjou henry deux
possesseurs de normandie bretagne et
aquitaine avait hérité du royaume
d'angleterre et depuis son énorme empire
plantagenêt il défiait la france yves
philippe auguste
le jeune roi de france y avait cependant
les idées claires
bien qu'âgé seulement de 15 ans il
voulait absolument s'imposer sur ces
grands seigneurs qui menaçait sa
couronne il doit alors la rébellion des
flandres et repoussa les attaques des
anglais mais devenu ami du fils d'henri
ii d'angleterre
richard coeur de lion une paix fut
négocié à cette époque le pape grégoire
lui préoccupé par le sort de jérusalem
aux mains des musulmans avaient appelé
les nobles chrétiens aux croisades
philippe auguste et richard coeur de
lion partir dont ensemble pour libérer
la terre sainte
mais leur amitié se transforma en
rivalité
à la mort de richard coeur de lion son
frère jean sans terre s'allie aux
germaniques et attaque la france
philippe auguste roi magnifique contre
attaque
il récupère la normandie par les anglais
à bouvines et confisqué à jean sans
terre ses possessions en france y
faisant comprendre à ses vassaux que
leurs ambitions ne sont plus acceptés
sous philippe auguste la france est
devenue la france est la nation la plus
riche et la plus peuplée la plus
puissante d'europe
le fils de philippe auguste louis 8 le
lion il joint le languedoc des
hérétiques cathares
profitant de la croisade contre les
albigeois et son fils louis 9 connu
comme saint louis pour sa sagesse et ses
valeurs morales continue les croisades
et développe la justice
en italie les gonfle y provoque l'appel
au secours du paf français urbain iv à
la france
qui
oui 9 répondit alors on te ment il
envoya une puissante armée commandée par
son frère charles dangereux mais ces
cruautés provoquèrent la révolte des
vêpres siciliennes le massacre de ses
hommes et son expulsion d'italie par les
espagnols d'aragon
le nouveau roi de france philippe le bel
en conflit avec l' empire germanique et
l'angleterre modernise à sa politique
avec l'institution des états généraux il
réunissait la noblesse le clergé et la
bourgeoisie qu'il consultait rentrer en
conflit avec le pape il institua une
papauté à avignon faisant naître un
grand schisme entre la papauté de rome
et la papauté d'avignon
philippe le bel roy innovateur ne laissa
pas d'héritier le trône de france passa
alors à philippe 6 de la famille cadette
des valois cela provoqua une terrible
colère d'edouard iii roi d'angleterre
qui prétendait à la couronne de france
en tant que petit fils de philippe le
bel
c'est le prélude de la guerre de cent
ans
l'armée anglaise attaque la france et
n'obéissant pas aux règles chevaleresque
inflige à philippe 6 de cuisantes
défaites
et tandis que l'autriche héritait du
saint-empire romain germanique et que la
suisse proclamait son indépendance en
france
le nouveau roi charles 5 héritait lui
d'une situation difficile les conflits
avec les anglais secoué le pays
de plus la peste noire avait tué un
tiers de la population et la bretagne
s'étaient alliés aux anglais pourtant
roi courageux charles 5 reconquiert la
plupart des territoires perdus et
rétabli l'ordre
mais quand son successeur charles ciss
est frappé par la folie le trône vacille
la couronne de france redevient l'objet
de convoitises s'ouvre alors une
terrible de lutte pour le pouvoir entre
les armagnacs au soutien de louis
d'orléans frère du roi et les
bourguignons
au soutien de jean sans peur ducs de
bourgogne qui avait élargi son duché en
héritant des flandres